Darci Lin just won America's Got Talent
how will she spend the million dollar
prize Plus Shania Twain on that
hilarious broad city cameo hey friends
this is the daily Deni you know it I
knew it
but last night 15 million people watched
twelve-year-old singing ventriloquist
Darci Lynn farmer being named the winner
of America's Got Talent
now the confetti has settled and as you
can imagine it has been a whirlwind
couple of hours for the Oklahoma native
but I caught up with Darcy Lynn just
this morning and let me tell you our
girl is tired I did not get any sleep
last night of course not what a night
it's been now that has it sunk in yet
that you want a GT no it hasn't
Oscar how you feeling now that Darcy has
won the whole dang thing I'm feeling
great because I'm gonna try to get the
money
[Applause]
and saying stop ahead stop crying you're
standing up there Tyra Banks is about to
announce you as the winner what was
going on in your head the longest 30
seconds of my life I was gonna say Tyra
Banks really stretch that out dish yes
like just spit it out I know a million
dollars for a twelve-year-old that's a
lot of money so I have to ask you have
you thought about how you want to spend
it yes I am
first things first I am definitely going
to give some to my church because they
always raise money for different
missions and mission programs and into
different countries so I'm definitely
going to do that and then second I have
to get my mom and dishwasher because or
fridge along with it you never know
because we definitely need more
household appliances and so you can get
up doing chores right yeah and a pug
torn apart really bad you want a puppy
you want a car we can make I'm sure
that's coming your way
I know mom come on in here hello I'm not
saying yes on analyze dishwasher huh mom
otherwise she's gonna be do a lot of
hand washing that's right
maybe Oscar can help with the dishes no
let me remind you Darcy is 12 years old
and she goes back to school on Monday
she told me it's gonna be crazy we have
more from my interview with Darcy Lin
last night just moments after she won
that's up now on ET online.com
all right the AGT finale was also filled
with some really fun performances and a
highlight for me was Shania Twain's duet
with Mandy Harvey but the Canadian queen
of country music bops
is busy because next week she drops her
first album in 15 years
last night she also made a hilarious
guest spot on broad city and let me give
you a little back story since season one
Abbey has lied about training Shania
and as fate would have it it finally
happened nice grip smile good you just
guest-starred on broad city what was it
like now that Abbi Jacobson has finally
trained Shania Twain I loved her I loved
the show I loved the whole environment
there and I'm just glad that she's
finally off the hook and she doesn't
have to keep this running line going
anymore when there's a spark you gotta
ride it
oh don't hide it oh now only are you
good Shania you're still the one I'm
sorry I had to gonna do that
all right speaking of her album you guys
she says she was way more nervous making
the record and she's relieved and can't
wait to share it her album now is
available September 29th I'm moving on
to another big finale last night the
winner of Big Brother season 19 was
chosen and the winner of the $500,000
prize
belongs to mr. Josh Martinez our very
own Bryce sander was with the reality
star just after his surprising win
congratulations Josh
[Applause]
has it sunk in yet
no shot not at all I don't even think I
won it's like crazy
where are you shocked and how close the
jury vote was I was completely shocked
which jury vote surprised you the most
oh do you Cody I'm like what Cody said
that his deciding factor was the fact
that you were up front and said to him I
don't like you
alright big money come in have you
thought about the first thing you're
gonna do with that money no idea
honestly an account in an account in an
account like I have no idea but I do
want to I know that me Paul and Krista's
we plan to a world tour I'm gonna stick
to my word we're gonna travel the world
together but and get back to my parents
you know my parents they don't want
anything they're like go start your life
but I want to get back to them Oh guys
I'm bummed because now that AGT and big
brother are over that means summer's
gone thankfully we do have fall TV
season to look forward to and also fall
music and tomorrow we'll have a preview
of the albums and tours we are excited
to close the year out with and until
then be sure to LIKE comment and share
and in case I don't think you guys
enough for watching thank you alright
I'm gonna sleep